Not long ago, in a galaxy not so far away, Star Wars toys were just lifeless plastic.
Enter BB-8, the new real-life Star Wars droid...
...who rolls around your house like the sidekick you always wanted.
BB-8 is the spiritual successor to our beloved R2-D2,...
...and will make his big screen debut in the coming Star Wars movie "The Force Awakens."
Just like the Hollywood version,...
...the 150-dollar take-home BB-8 boops and bops around with this mushroom-shaped head...
...that magically stays on top.
Made by a toy robot startup called "Sphero,"...
...BB-8 takes commands via Bluetooth from your smartphone.
It's like a little remote control car you can drive around or send off on patrol.
Watch him react to your voice.
It's a trap!
Look around.
He can even beam holographic messages...
...via augmented reality visualizations on your phone screen.
The Incom T-70 X-Wing fighter.
BB-8's personality comes from this little head.
As he bobs, twists and at times drunkenly struggles to keep upright,...
...it's hard not to fall in love.
If you do manage to knock off his head,...
...thankfully it pops back on with the force of magnetism.